good morning Millennials happy birthday
Claudia yes it is she
I can't I used to always say like I'm
never gonna work on my birthday but like
what else is there is it but if you
didn't do the toast today you would have
woken up later and now you have a little
more birthday time you and I had a full
day already like right look tomorrow but
you're making the most of your birthday
and I get to hang out with your best
friend your fellow Millennials I totally
under knee I've already got some very
interesting birthday wishes people are
up so early these days I know empty out
on the west coast what I know he never
sleeps that's true because Hollywood
never sleeps right and the creepiness in
Hollywood never speaks sleep speaking of
which our latest patreon episode is out
wow that feels like forever ago we
filmed it are we cut how did you feel
about this apartment for the first time
and it was a premium experience I'm so
very premium I got the full tour you did
a really good job for someone who says
that they but just were not into design
like it's very well designed
thank you very much that really means
the world to me because you know how
much anxiety I I know right you still
need to move the couch over six inches
but it's right no but I told you then
the TV might have entered well no we
just need to put something there that
wouldn't make sense like a really pretty
look a lamp yeah anyways at my apartment
we filmed a premium patreon episode
where we dissected all of the most
salacious nd blinds from July 4th a lot
of you get confused by Black blinds it's
confusing they're a riddle it's a great
beginners guide if you're just getting
into blinds and it's also just juicy as
hell if you've been reading blogs for
years right and we just have to thank
Andy for constantly serving a premium
content just like us we have so much in
common and you should go check it out
patreon.com/scishow and like I know I
keep saying this but like it's a big
deal and it was very treacherous I had
lots of technical difficulties but we
prevailed nonetheless presale goes on I
think for one or two more days and then
on Friday everyone can get access there
will still be tickets left and that's it
very exciting oh also I made a joke on
the show that don't get me a gift just
been with me money for drinks and like I
woke up to $80 in my venmo and like
that's not what I meant
like I was joking and I'm gonna donate
it all to Gift of Life
I encourage everyone else that in honor
of my birthday instead of it buying
myself drink why don't you donate that
$5 to the Gift of Life registry or get a
swab kit and donate your bone marrow I'm
in the system and now I think like three
or four hundred toasters are in the
system when we have our own little
circle it's a circle yeah or they can
mend my un yells ammonia correct yes
that might be easiest for people
sometimes yeah but like that seems shady
to me people are collecting my money on
my personal bed mo why I don't know as
long as you don't need it you're in the
clear I know it just feels wrong just do
it yourself that - um in another very
robust episode of the toast today we
have a well rounded wealth of stories I
felt really good about yesterday's show
for like changing it up and I also
noticed and they felt like we just like
I use different parts of my brain and I
I felt funny or smart or better and I
also felt like we were having good maybe
not so implications like I understand
what your cushions yeah like like the
toes and effectively we're having like a
positive effect on toasty conversations
cuz our morning shows Facebook group
which is incredibly robust 30,000 of the
best toasters feel free to join
we're always sharing like articles about
Selena & handli and I go that's a I
found like people were having much more
intellectual conversations like
especially about the plastic debacle and
I don't know I just think it's great I
think we should we should extend our
hearts and smart we should and so
without getting into the Fast Five first
I wanted to update everyone on the story
of the tie boys because I didn't want to
dedicate a new story to because there's
just so much news to discuss these days
yeah but the boys have been rescued by
both their coach they didn't use Elon
Musk submarine but they have it yes
and I'm just so happy for everyone
involved I'm thinking of the family of
the Thai Navy SEAL who lost his life
they were in there for two weeks that's
crazy so what did they do what did they
eat right I they were able to like send
stuff down so I think once them if the
authorities got there they sent down
like resources but like that's what I
think of the most like the sheer boredom
that's true but I guess it that makes it
better being with right not alone yeah
then also it's like Lord of the Flies
you know someone gets out of control
right but like if I was there I'd like
be running the soccer team okay if you
were
there you would be so hungry oh my god I
would be miserable we have no energy if
I was kidnapped like they would
literally let me go after a couple hours
because I would not stop complaining
totally and you would probably cost them
more and like of course anything
expensive me to get for you like I'm a
period can I get a tampon totally like
no I would have a full list of demands
right and they would let you go so
anyways we're very happy about this
happy news and that never really works
out and I'm so excited for the movie
about it it's gonna be wonderful
do you think there's gonna be a movie of
course always a movie and these days the
turnaround is so quick it's like they
probably started filming before the boys
got out no they started filming before
this even happened right and now they
just had now they have maybe this was
all employed from the yeah like when
Mandela came out like literally Nelson
Mandela like wasn't even in the ground
yet that's great it's so crazy but
slowly took a long time now that I think
about it because you're Clint Eastwood
was trying to figure out how to make a
villain and then he just made some [ __ ]
up and it was crazy because people
really think the NK TSB was trying to
rag on Sully when they were in called
fiction silly got free but you can't
make a movie and who's gonna be the
villain the birds know it's just awkward
even if they are it's a movie based on a
true story that's also a lot that took
some liberties yeah artistic routes yeah
you say route or route depends route 66
route artistic yeah yura or era
it depends it's the end of an era
but it's the Mesozoic era right Mesozoic
era is from friends cuz Ross is a
paleontologist it's all about dinosaurs
by the way I know you're obsessed with
Massapequa and I know you're obsessed
with comedians in cars getting coffee
have you seen the Kate McKinnon episode
so I just started the new season
yesterday and hear my thoughts I didn't
get to keep me hidden yet I'm sure it's
amazing cuz she's [ __ ] hilarious and
there's a really think there's a really
long thing that Massapequa and you're
going to die really yeah does she
reference friends oh no oh yes but so I
watch the first one or watch Zach
Galifianakis and I watch I - it was okay
I was a little disappointed I thought it
was a weird one to start off with
because he's not like obviously funny
and I thought that there episode was
like kind of bad but then at the end
they put in the episode between two
ferns which was hysterical
I thought the opposite I felt like their
episode was cute sack Calvin hawk is
like he's just not
ya know he is and I loved him he just
makes me a little sad cuz like no when
he was like so uh Seinfeld that was a
great springboard for a lot of white
people like it was like I think I
thought the second part was way funnier
I thought the first one I was like I
thought the second part was we were
considering like now I know he's just
like acting and that Jerry's acting and
now am i doing my actors yeah it's like
when they did the episode with the
Miranda sings girl they put her YouTube
video that she made with Jerry in the
beginning and it was like so awkward
they were like acting and like it wasn't
funny
and then the episode stunk too so
irrelevant yeah I know I I was like a
little like I wasn't loving oh so
excited for the season to come out and
then I wasn't loving the first episode
but I will get there because I really
want to see Ellen and I really want to
special entertainer oh and then start
watching Dave Chappelle and I was just
lost I'm like the less I'm not Dave
Chappelle's target audience it's fine
and I just didn't really understand and
he's like he's a tough like he scares me
and it's your favorite comedian living
because you can't say Joan Rivers Jim
Gaffigan okay
like and his episode of communities and
cars really again so funny who it was
the best episode you've seen that's a
good question I like to Steve Harvey I
will have to say I think that's my
favorite one Steve Harvey yeah also I
was reading an episode of the New York
Post and it's like the 10th season of
comedians in cars it's a live in five
people are just lying now yeah that's
what they do I don't know if you know
that it's actually I do it's just like
it's it's not like a subjective thing
it's like were there five seasons where
they're dead and like who the hell broke
ten seasons look I don't know how do
they sell enough cars total we'll see
you could tell that the cars have gone
downhill
yeah in the first season the cars were
very cool and the editing was like super
weird and like poor Nate but now that
they're like legit with Netflix like
it's less poorni but the cards like they
ran out of all the cool ones like hidden
driving that Nazi mobile and you
couldn't hear anything because it was a
convertible it was just it's alright
okay um anyways we ready get into the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take it by that
of your morning host I am so hungry yes
okay
first story is an update from
yesterday's story and I'm
just like a little bit shook to the core
because like Justin Bieber confirmed
that he's in a Charlie Baldwin with a
beautiful sweet message praising hailey
praising Jesus praising the Lord
praising the toast praising Carlin's
praising the toast forgetting it alright
yeah I think you really did get her hit
the nail on the head and you know what
like I know I'm I'm good but I didn't
think I was like that I know in the
video you made for the Instagram was
hysterical because I just kept thinking
like to toast said this at 10:30 Justin
Bieber said this at 6:30 someone needs
to spell that out for the masses no
Jackie basically like we were just
giving theories I'm like what this could
possibly mean and she was like I just
think that they're too like devout
Christians who want to get married young
and like are really brought together by
the spirit of this church that they're a
part of and while I definitely agree I
want to offer one just one but let me
just alter can I say what he drew and
then give us your alternative Justin
Bieber took to Instagram to confirm his
engagement to Haley Baldwin quote was
gonna wait a while to say anything but
word word travels fast
listen plain and simple Haley I am so in
love with everything about you so
committed to spending my life getting to
know every single part of you loving you
patiently and kindly I promise to lead
our family with honor and integrity
letting Jesus through His Holy Spirit
guide us in everything we do in every
decision we make my heart is completely
and fully yours and I will always put
you first you are the love of my life
Haley Baldwin and I wouldn't want to
spend it with anybody else you make me
so much better and we complement each
other so well can't wait for the best
season of life yet hold on God's timing
really is literally perfect we got
engaged on the seventh day of the
seventh month the number seven is the
number of spiritual perfection it's true
google it isn't that nuts by the way I
didn't plan that anyways my goodness
does feel good to have our future
secured we're gonna be better at 70 baby
here we go alright the caption was like
a little chronically incorrect what I
can look past it I can look past it too
right
he's excited enthusiastic he was my
alternative theory because I do believe
I actually like weirdly thing Justin
Bieber is like genuine look he he has
nothing to gain from this you know what
he means
I agree with that and what the blinds
say are about they say about Haley
Baldwin
like she needs money I'm like she needs
Fame
she needs jobs so it's possible that
Justin Bieber is completely genuine in
his love for Jesus and his love for
hailey and his excitement about this
engagement and she might be too but her
motives might be questionable that's all
I'm gonna say okay
and I think that's fair like you know
what's the same the ends justify the
means
yes so I think that they have a lot in
common maybe like this happens to be
extremely beneficial for her I think
she's gained like 6 million followers
and then I not Justin Bieber he does not
follow his fiancee on Instagram and
might I add that was discovered by a
girl on the toast and then eonline wrote
it up like everyone needs to stop
poaching from our group and not giving
us credit sorry right at least give us
credit like take what you want but just
be like in the morning toast is the
greatest thing since sliced bread
literally yeah the new Kathie Lee and
Hoda that's literally all you have to
say Elon Musk's favorite morning show
mm-hmm five stars says us so anyways if
you want to know what's going on in
Hollywood you need to watch the show
clearly because we weren't June we're in
tune with what's I'm sorry and I think
it has a lot to do with the blinds
because they a horse it helps us look at
things more clearly a little bit more
cynically yes oh my god I had an amazing
analogy today would you like to hear it
I would love to know that episode of Sex
in the City when Miranda finds out she's
having a boy and like every time someone
asks her she's like oh yeah it's a boy
and they're like Miranda and she's like
she fixes up that's like what I've been
doing on my birthday people like it's
your birthday and I'm like you know yeah
but is there something deeper
like how Miranda didn't want a kid you
like totally hated Brady not like wanna
celebrate I don't want to do in 24 yeah
okay I'm saying 20 actually I'm gonna
take what 22 but for a girl who doesn't
want to celebrate her birthday like you
are you're making a a week of it well
like Thursday right I'm not actually
Bennis Oh actually ask any girl these
are against your wishes I not I wanted
to have like a nice soiree there's an
additional people to get drunk in my
honor that's lovely and if I can help
facilitate an open bar great but this
whole weekend thing been doing in the
Hamptons like is in my sin I'm like I
actually think I don't wanna go he's
like sorry no oh well keep us posted
I'm sure I wake up on Friday with the
terrible hangover and like pit in my
stomach and not wanna go well I don't
think we'll be doing the show on Friday
I'm just
yeah cuz I'm making some after party
plans - right we're gonna be fair
warning by some miracle if we're up at
6:00 a I'm dying to do the show we'll be
here but barring that barring a true
miracle we won't be here or like maybe
let's ask if we could just like go live
at noon or we could do a podcast lovely
podcast so come over I'll give you
another five or one bar oh yeah okay
next story George Clooney is involved in
a scooter crash in Italy you guys first
of all while I was looking for a robust
stories I found out that scooters are
taking over the world
I knew that uber like is investing in a
scooter startup and you'll be able to
rent scooters like you got an uber which
is unbelievably necessary because Buber
has gone down the tubes the drivers are
taking you on a wild goose chase around
the city yeah as opposed to your actual
that's also wishing in lieu of like
spikes fine except like I would take a
bite cuter that he was on is not know he
was like being like a Vespa right we're
talking about like a razor he was being
like a 20 year old sergeant he has her
scooters like how [ __ ] sick they were
we should have a race to do tricks yeah
we were sick we were sick bro we were so
sick and like that
no but it was like we were four girls
like doing like tricks on scooter right
as it was like the best of the work yet
totally and like we were like kind of
like boyish and we learned pokemons we
were very big time boys we love sports I
were a sweatband in my hair every single
day to school yes high pony always
always we just like loved doing on the
trampoline like we were very active no
and we were real tomboy he's growing
yeah he wouldn't have thought that we
would end up like night like the beauty
guru allergic to sports right no I still
enjoy sports but they're hard to find
like you have to seek them out you have
to like just join a local league well
that's like people join corporate
leagues an attack that's how I met Zack
and the toast doesn't have a corporate
team oh my god now we have to start one
necessarily yeah we should play Central
Park there are a lot of places to play
yeah when you used to play we would play
on the west side by the car dealership
right good times great times and it
should definitely be a soccer league
because soccer is the best sport
it's so much running they know more so
than others I think right but it's such
I don't know I just really feel like you
got your pound of flesh from soccer like
kickball you're on the bench old hymen
on sale of kickball I've had to see home
didn't spend my time on the bench
because I got all dressed up and keep to
the Westside to sit some more no I don't
know I was just when when the World Cup
was on Ben was watching it I was just
thinking like this is like the worst
sport to have to play like so much
running yeah but I feel just so much
bigger than other fields yeah but I'm
not going I'm not seeking out sports
just too lazy to take it around no
totally I agree but I want the full
experience okay so this is what happened
to George Clooney Hollywood star George
Clooney was released from the hospital
after suffering minor injuries Tuesday
while riding a scooter on the Italian
island of Sardinia where he is shooting
a TV minutes miniseries according to
reports the 57 year old actor and
director had just left his hotel and was
riding the scooter when I collided with
her Mercedes near Olbia according to the
Telegraph Clooney was thrown over the
top of the scooter after the car failed
to stop at a turn according to
Carabinieri paramilitary police officer
the motorist stopped and called for help
the news outlet reported so he's fine
okay he's fine and now that he's finding
she want to be like what 60 year-old
[ __ ] is on a scooter on a cobblestone
kermy street in Italy like be smart you
have kids like don't be taking risks
like that I hate people who are just
like deliberately dangerous like like
I'm sorry jumpy living on the edge
jumping out of a plane it's like
literally the most unnecessary thing
ever like I will not ever jump out of a
plane and I will live a very full life
look I just hate when people like test
god here's the thing but you wouldn't
think that riding on a scooter is
testing I do know a scooter this is like
a it's a good motorcycle basically like
when you're you just had give to babies
at home a wife you're an older man and
you're on a curvy cobblestone Italian
road like I'm sorry I just hate like
when youtubers like film themselves like
on the top of like mountains and cliffs
like dangling off like you're dumb like
I hate when people test God like stop
like you weren't made to jump out of a
plane it's unnatural you may just sit in
them barely I agree I just don't think
writing a best buzz coming out of a
plane but I hear you know what's not but
like I feel like at some point like do
you notice I like as you get older at
least for me like I'm more scared on
planes now than I was as a kid
yes I've so much more to lose like I
know that if I died like you would be
devastated and that's good Theo
look I just I know you can so I like to
think that if I died a lot of people
would be upset the toasters so like I
just think about
that I have liked and I get much more
scared and I'm much more safe and I'm
much more like weenie now than I was
back then
and I find myself doing like less
adventurous things because like I have a
life and a family and they're like I
don't need to test the Lord I see that
so like what is the six-year-old man
doing today - George Clooney needs to
get a little wee me inside of him yeah
like I if God willing when I have
children like I'm literally like driving
myself everywhere you gotta be safe
yeah you definitely have to be safe in
safety first but I will say I'm what did
I do recently oh I skied and there was
something about doing something I had
never done before and really pushing
myself and challenging my body that was
very nice I still would not equate that
with George Clooney no but I remember
being on that same mountain with you and
being like what the [ __ ] am i doing I'm
testing the Lord right now I could have
totally died like it's very dangerous
you were not on it people die all the
diversity even on an incline we really
truly but I know that if I if I kept
going and I got good of it I would've
been like let's go to a higher mountain
you know you would not have said that
but I did what if it had left and had
lunch and we wouldn't have let you and
the mountains have went on we're very
sane people like I do not test God
anymore like I'm I have a family so
you're no longer taking airplanes that I
think is like the most extreme thing
I'll do like when I took the blade I got
off and I was like what the hell am i
doing I agree I'm not doing that anymore
and I'm no longer taking unnecessary
trips like weekends here and there no
thanks that's I'll take the train fine
yes like I just think that like we come
from like a generation now the
Millennials it's more like live you live
taking rest Jim better play think don't
don't
it's so stupid I agree okay this next
story is really sweet and finally some
good plain dog news plane plane crew
comes to rescue of dog with oxygen mask
her flight this was a really sweet story
- have you seen it no I haven't heard
claim passengers rarely describe air
travel as a breath of fresh air but it
was literally that for one family's
Bulldog on a recent JetBlue flight the
french bulldog named Arsene was on a
flight from florida in massachusetts on
thursday when she started showing signs
of distress according to his owner
Michelle Burt the three-year-old
Bulldogs tongue began to turn blue and
she was happy having difficulty
breathing quote we are all affected by
cabin pressure and oxygen fluctuations
human canine and feline
etc but the fact that the attendants
were responsive and attempted to the
situation may have saved artsy's life
the crew came to rescue with an oxygen
mask for Darcy the photos which have
since spread across social media showed
the Bulldog being treated for hypoxia
the photos are cute but hypoxia elack's
a lack of oxygen in the body coming
deadly I place the mask over her face
I'm within a few minutes she became
alert and after a short time she didn't
want the mask so they put an oxygen mask
over the dog's mouth because she was
having trouble beating which is so
beautiful so smart my thinking JetBlue
of course was a wonderful line but what
if this happened to a Czech dog who
would have been there I don't think they
check songs anymore they do I don't know
about JetBlue but airlines still check
dogs we hear about it every day near the
book they kill horses don't they yeah
they check dogs don't they do not on
Sully please I want to go back to my
rant real quick about the risks because
now everyone's like we went snowmobiling
and I couldn't agree more like remember
the first day we went snowmobiling went
on the lovely like the regular track
with all the the proper precautions and
then the next day we were feeling risky
and we let that guy take us like to the
top of the mountain and like when I was
on my way up there I was like what are
we doing I wasn't loving it but like
that's a great point
don't test God know your limits the
first day was perfect we took the route
everyone else take we were with a group
big group we were safe then us going off
track railroading upstate like whatever
what were we doing you are such a liar
because no one was enjoying it more than
you know what is enjoying going more
than you and not for one second and
we're even going again and you've never
said oh we shouldn't we shouldn't do
that rough road ok no I you know what
really woke me up when we were on that
rough road oh he was having like the
worst time ever and we turn around and
Olivia Margo are there and it was like 6
o'clock it was almost getting dark and
there was not a spot of cell phone
service and then I was like this is dumb
like we should go down now like you
realize like the possible implications
and it really puts you into perspective
like I would do the regular track any
day it's very safe it's flatland there's
lots of people around lots of
instructors like when we were going
off-roading you know what if we just
offered it earlier in the day still I
didn't think it was a good idea there
was no there was animals up there there
was no track I don't know I'm so excited
to play this episode for you when we're
back in Utah and you're like yeah let's
go faster no or like when
I would always in the procession of
things I like to go behind you because I
like to leave so I don't I don't
tailgate like you but you when you would
go behind me you're like up my butt like
that's her that's her I didn't say
anything
you won't even stop me beg you guys go
so slow I did not think about the
airplane what don't you think I said
again remember you said when we were in
Nashville seeing you still don't even
remember you something about like
transporting well yeah we I may even
nationalize like wow it's so crazy if
you just get on a plane and get off mere
hours later and you're in a totally
different land and you were like if I
completely agree I was singing the same
thing never sell bad numbers ok ok ok
next story in branding news Schmucker is
saying goodbye to Pillsbury and it's
Doughboy means I'm out of a job
what yeah was I mean JM Smucker is a
offloading Pillsbury and other baking
brands the company known for products
like Smuckers Jem Jif peanut butter and
filters coffee and now announced Monday
that it would be selling its baking
business to private equity firm Brynwood
the partners for three hundred and
seventy five million dollars the deal
includes the Pillsbury hungry Jack
Martha white right Willie white Willie
and Jim Dandy brands some [ __ ] said
in the statement the move comes during a
period of turmoil for big food brands
which are facing challenges navigating
shoppers changing tastes smoker CEO mark
smoker said selling the baking because
growing up with a name like Schmucker uh
it'd be [ __ ] lit as hell
well yeah cuz you're rich but like
imagine if it wasn't like a
multi-million dollar bread and you were
just like Jackie Schmucker the bullying
the mugger runs with [ __ ] Thank You
smoker CEO mark Schmucker who had a hard
time growing up said selling the baking
business will help more the more than
120 120 year old company focused on
bolstering its pet food Co coffee and
snack offerings while the decision today
best
these brands was difficult it
underscores our commitment to allocating
resources toward those areas of business
critical to our growth the Pillsbury
Doughboy originally known as pop and
fresh first appeared in TV commercials
more than fifty years ago so I guess
that means they have a picture of the
Pillsbury Doughboy float from the Macy's
Day Parade
I guess he's out of the job - okay
here's the thing this brand like when
they're saying that they couldn't keep
up with shoppers changing food habits
like me as a food brand you literally
have no excuse to not succeed people
will always eat like yes a mom-and-pop
book store like I understand you being
out of business the times are changing
but like times changing has nothing to
do with people want to eat jelly um no I
don't know about jelly but like they
definitely serve like have a lot of
fattening foods and everyone's all about
organic gluten free that's everyone that
we know but like America is not yes and
no but like then how do you explain the
success of Whole Foods the success of
Whole Foods I would bet my life is in
like the coastal and more urban areas
whereas like I don't think there's a pop
in tofu the Whole Foods in Huntsville
Alabama I bet you it's very hipster
that's what everyone says no but look
that's not real America like this New
York in LA is fake like I agree it's not
real okay there and things that are
popular here like are popular here
because people who like right for the
New York Times live in New York but
that's not real America like it's not I
agree you don't need quinoa in real
America real America live in real
America
America is still eating pillsbury but
less and less people know like the
crescents yeah look people love those I
know also like wonderful songs the
frosting from the jar the best I think
they were trying to make that happen and
like it's sort of stuck Crystal Crescent
yeah I know so because real America
doesn't say croissant that's true
actually
they say Crescent like this is sad to me
this is sad to me
but Pillsbury going out is like the
elitist quinoa eating organic non-gmo
[ __ ] from New York
are winning and I'm not here so no I'm
sorry Pillsbury is not going out it's
just being sold and maybe Brynwood
partners has better system in place and
it wouldn't be being sold if it was
popping off finance actually yes it
would cuz that's how you make money or
you cut your losses that's true actually
we don't know we don't know
it's so popular Rutgers couldn't handle
the demand no it's so popular with
Britain we just had to have it
I think Hills very is doing just fine
I hope so and I hope that Britain would
keeps the Doughboy because he's an
inspiration to us all and I hope more
brands like Pillsbury and that they're
full of artificial flavors continue to
grow and prosper because that's what
this nation was built on travitt
officiality and trans-fats I agree I'm
just like okay I get I understand like
being healthy and there should
definitely be like a couple specialty
food stores that like sell organic and
non-gmo but like the biggest supermarket
should not be Whole Foods I'm sorry well
you could blame Amazon for that yeah but
now you know you get like a special
Prime membership if you're like a Whole
Foods number two or something like that
I will not go to Whole Foods ever I've
never been I've been I think I got some
limes there once which was fine because
I would like some organic lime sure to
me Trader Joe's is like the lesser evil
of Whole Foods and they were really like
the oh geez I agree because it's like
Trader Joe's it's like they didn't take
the taste out of the equation right and
like they still sell everything there is
organic and non-gmo but it's still
fattening with like I get the best
chocolate animal crackers from there yes
yeah you know exactly snacks you know
they still sell so they still sell fat
yeah Whole Foods like doesn't have a
snack like I understand wanting to be
healthy from like a chemical standpoint
but like let me eat chocolate I agree
and you know what I can do without some
chemicals of course of course some I
don't know okay ready for our fifth and
final story which actually brings me up
to a very important point that I've been
meaning to make Bravo sets late-night
talk show exact produced by Andy Cohen
and Jerry O'Connell here's the pitch
this is by deadline very well Barry show
these are what we call the trades
rabbie media has given the green light
to real men watch Bravo a new late-night
talk show executive produced by Andy
Cohen and Jerry O'Connell with O'Connell
to host set for premiere this fall which
brings me to my point that I wanted to
mention because we have a new Facebook
group called I'm in love with the
toaster and is for also Nona's
um in love with the toaster toes people
are like in business to what I was going
tour and that's exactly what I was going
for but even though they came up with a
better name for themselves and it's the
Brewster's I didn't want to assume that
all toasts are significant others are
rose great call exactly that
we don't see gender here and I was
keeping it gender-neutral you don't
think I thought of all these things gee
I keep using turns significant out there
so granola so anyway it's a griever
toaster significant others who can join
fellow to us or significant others and
then about the fact that their toaster
lover is in a group online wants to take
out of the mountains for we get talking
to Internet lastly it's become my
absolute favorite coupe I made been join
and like I just lurk because I don't
want them to feel like mom's watching
they wouldn't snitch but they did want
to shout out on the show which goes
against me saying I wouldn't snitch but
it's hysterical it's hysterical and wait
some guy yes last night posted and like
I think everyone thought he was joking
but he was 100% legit he's like how did
I get what is this group how did I get
here and I thought it was a joke and
everyone was like oh your wife did
probably put it here like it's for for
the toasters he's like no seriously what
is the toast like this girl's but I'm
sure this girl likes put her husband in
there like he had no idea what he was
doing there at first I thought he was
kidding it like being sarcastic but he
was 100% authentic
that's so ya know and doing the and
mission port is kind of tough because
they just I need to like cross-reference
that these men are truly in love with
the toaster and women are in love with
the toaster but um it's been very
rewarding yeah and so if you or someone
you love is struggling with the fact
that you are a toaster please have them
to have them seek help at WWF
hp.com/support less I'm in love with a
toaster family slash a bunch of numbers
after that so speaking of I'm sure this
group is the target audience for real
men watch Bravo hmm each episode will
feature O'Connell alongside a panel of
male celebrities comics and tastemakers
discussing the buzziest Bravo moments in
a variety of topics steeped in pop
culture the description / Bravo
O'Connell from offering advice to the
Real Housewives from every franchise to
taking sides on some of the most
controversial Bravo feuds Jerry is truly
a walking encyclopedia Bravo history
real men watch Bravo will offer
unprecedented access to the male point
of view pertaining to all things Bravo
and entertainment whether realizing they
were a die-hard Vanderpump rules fan
after being introduced to the sizzling
series by their girlfriends are learning
how to cook the perfect leg from brick
binging Top Chef episodes for hours
these men are unapologetic Bravo holux
and hope to encourage others to step out
of the shadows and admit what some have
known all along real men
I have two thoughts about this the
casting of Jerry O'Connell is [ __ ]
brilliant because every time he's on
watch happens I'm just like even more
and more enthralled with him like he
really is he knows everything he's been
watching Bravo for years so he's gonna
be a great host he's great on TV he has
lots of experience he's gonna watch
opens live a lot and he has a wealth of
knowledge - my only concern about this
show is that this is now the third show
in the weekly Bravo lineup that's like
like very similar to watch opens I've
and Kandi Koated nights again it's I
think they're all just serving different
demographics like one's male ones female
but I don't know it just seems too
similar to have three of like virtually
the same show just recapping Bravo shows
I agree I feel like I don't know how
this is gonna pan out but I don't like
see it I don't I don't know I'm just
trying to think who potential roundtable
guests would be they'll have like Jack's
on and they'll have like people who act
Bravo what's that guy's name the
barstool enemy rap oh man totally he
should have a policy and he should be a
host - good that's a good call yeah yeah
no it's just it's it's a great name it's
a great name I look forward to seeing
what they do but yeah I agree with you
like they need to get some more original
programming under their belt like and
stop doing copycat shows it's like they
aren't scamming by the motto if it ain't
broke don't fix it but definitely not
broke why don't you buy something else
right and like I feel like they used to
be so innovative like when they came up
with the idea for below deck and been
different pearls at the same time which
are both like honestly crazy ideas like
a show about waitresses and a show about
yachties like but they both turned out
to be smash successes so I don't think
they're thinking outside the box anymore
I agree that's upsetting I agree like
the last two shows that they've
announced our copies of a show they
already have kandi and Jerry also
speaking of new shows I just wanted to
touch on Barry Cavallari because I
watched it and I watched it with the
toasters they did a massive first of all
you guys are [ __ ] hilarious and like
thank you for confirming everything I
thought it's like - Dale's premise where
it's more so about the people that work
in her store and like so much she's so
great and funny and like cute and it's
weird because Jay does not give a [ __ ]
about what people think about him and
he's like very like stoic but almost
like being kind of mean and right what I
had heard just feedback was that he came
off as like a dick he did and then like
the more and then I was reading what the
toasters were saying and they were like
he doesn't care that there's a film
camera in his homies
like be different like thirsty and
annoying and I kind of appreciated that
but it was kind of like pulling teeth
and she's so cute and great that even
when he's being an [ __ ] she's just
like laughed it off you know she's
gorgeous I could just watch her just
being herself no totally they it had its
moments
I wouldn't write it off completely um
but it's definitely not the hills part
tail no no I don't think anyone expected
it and I think that when he tries he is
basically trying to do what Bravo does
and like make shows about people who
work places like below jacket been
different roles
I think - Ellis is like the best example
of how not good that he is that it
because that was truly the worst show I
agree um maybe this will turn around I
don't know did you ever hear about the
show what happens at the Abbey
yeah do you know what happened to it
what happened to Daddy
it was - I want another think about it
they have what happened at the Abbey dvf
show Cosmo very Cavallari and - Styles
all five except for very careful area we
don't know huge failures well what
happens at the Abbey was actually
[ __ ] crazy and amazing and had the
underpin girls potential because the
cast like every week it was like a whole
shift in the paradigm yeah and I wonder
what happened to it I even followed one
of them on Instagram after it's a family
well like he hasn't been able to make a
good show since Kardashian's I know they
had a job with Fashion Police and then
they were never able to pick up the
pieces
hijo de bellas total Bella's yes and
total divas is good I like Toby was like
I've been watching total Bella's like
what I been [ __ ] on Sunday and I'm so
obsessed with it I'm so obsessed with
Nikki her and John are not together
right now I know when after all that the
drama happened they eventually got back
together but that was a lie and ever the
world believed that they had a happily
ever after but they never got back
together and I think that their breakup
I know we toyed with this idea on the
show and I wouldn't refuse to believe it
because John Cena is so above it but
after watching on the show it made me
think that the breakup was like fake
that the whole thing was right that it
was like a press thing so I don't even
know what the hell's going on he also
has a model squad coming up Oh dad I
watched the one teaser episode and it
looks really good I'm gonna give Matt a
chance I don't know it's just like ela
can't get their [ __ ] together
no like Kardashians and total divas what
else I mean literally their last amazing
show was pretty wild
and that must have been 15 years ago and
it was like it wasn't even a success
while it was on its kids was good yeah
but they but it was good fell to like
failure after trip here and now they're
picking up is he Phillips lady game
I don't know anything about lading but
people love them and honestly if they
can set a good precedent for podcasters
getting TV shows here for it
agreed next thing we need to talk about
is the bachelor okay so I watched I know
you've been because I just happened to
be like home alone on the couch with the
remote and I hand out like eight twenty
and I was like hey I found myself in the
same position at eight eleven I was like
sure let me flip it up and it was cold
since I was like oh of course I watched
she was being so cute and what preceded
in the next twenty minutes was so
unbelievably abhorrent that I am now
officially completely written off the
show because he told her he was a virgin
and first of all she needed a minute
which by the way is so offensive like
imagine if the gender roles were
reversed and a guy like got a sweet girl
like Emily Maynard she didn't want to
sleep with any other guy she didn't but
she was like she was just like I'm just
not gonna have sex with a million guys
very respectable but like when a boy
does it it's weird and like I guess it's
a little weird that he's 26 and was like
in the NFL and like it's famous and
dated a famous person and like didn't
have sex and it's it's bizarre but like
it's not as Tara like when the guys were
all at home debriefing they're like yes
she he has to tell her like she's not
gonna be cool about it like talking
about like he literally has a venereal
disease like that if she touches him
she'll die like it was so disgusting and
like rude and like yes I can admit that
it's definitely a little off but to be
talking about it so negatively and like
so like trying to embarrass him like no
god forbid like there's one nice boy on
the show one nice guy who's not gonna
[ __ ] a million girls and get chlamydia
like I was getting so angry like how
people were talking about him and then
like beckylyn getting up and being all
dramatic like that's rude that's a say
that's so weird like he literally it's
probably so embarrassing for him to say
and she's just like I need a minute what
the hell do you need a minute for what
did you do she went outside and looked
at her nails and then came back inside
I'm sorry it was so just like it was
just a 20 minute said I was like this is
disgusting like we're like making him
like an outcast when like literally he's
just a nice guy and he's not disgusting
like everyone else on the show I think
the gender roles were reversed it would
be like a prate like guys love girls who
having had sex with a million guys they
don't want to have a vagina and it's not
been all around the world it's not like
he said he was waiting for marriage like
if they did get engaged they could have
sex and she could take the hard sweet
way he's like it's not a marriage thing
it's a love thing a heart thing sorry
like I
that was the nail in the coffin for me i
am a fit and I turned it off and I
didn't watch anymore because I actually
watched a little bit at the date with
Gary because I think he's interesting
but I'm officially like nail in the
coffin done with the Batchelor franchise
I'll watch bachelor in paradise
but I'm officially done okay very fair
and I completely agree with you
cool she is not good enough for Colt in
like he no one is except for snitch and
I look forward to meeting our brother
and mom apparently Becca tweeted that
they edited her getting up and that she
really just went to the bathroom I don't
believe it
that would be so [ __ ] out ya own
bachelor part but honestly I wouldn't
put anything past that yeah um I
literally was watching sitting on my
couch and I just could not even even
when I'm looking at the TV
I couldn't even pay attention like I
couldn't even process what was happening
I like Blake he looks like miles teller
and Garrett and Colton and I liked wills
and now he's gone obviously how's Leo
still there okay so when I turned it on
the guy with long hair was still there
and I don't really don't know anyone any
but I've seen so much about him he's in
a porno it's not even that he has long
hair it's that he is a soft corn corn
star and like I've just seen a lot about
him like being like a weenie and I'm
like oh he's like a joke turned on he's
like in the top five I'm like what the
[ __ ] going on they're talking about
hometowns I'm like the long-haired guy
still here well I think someone made an
amazing call that he has to go on
paradise and date Becca Martinez just to
think it's my chair maybe he never knows
she's not in Marin dice you know it
there's like people are saying that
she's pregnant yeah I don't know about
that I don't know about that either but
then like now you know one put someone
put something in your head and now you
can't see not through that lens like
when someone tell me a rumor about
Taylor Swift like I was like that's all
I can like see so now all I can see is
Becca Becca Martinez is pregnant yeah
same well now long haired guy is gone oh
he is yeah the final four are Colton
smooth Garrett Blake and the guy with
the slicked back hair
so here's the thing this is my
prediction now that it's tough for I I
think we know Colton doesn't win yeah
and I think we also know he can't be the
bachelor cuz he's on paradise and he's
with Tia yeah then I think that guy
Garrett wins and then that leaves the
other two for possible bachelor
candidates
I don't even know them enough to like
think that they're interesting so but
the only one who would be a good
bachelor is Blake but I think well my
bracket thanks me that he'll be number
two usually they don't make number two
the bachelor but they have been but
Becca's number two people are so
actually that was different because like
one half and Jojo was number two yes
people are saying that Ben Higgins is
gonna be the bachelor again so here for
it right oh my god you're kidding me I
have an absolute love and adoration for
Bella I love and adore Ben Higgins but I
just feel like and he's hot I just the
crop of girls that they're like that
he's gonna have to sift through like
what I was gonna say that he's got an
amazing crop of girls right but he's
just attracts good this season was an
interesting time it was like no prob
didn't know that they would literally
leave the show with a million followers
and now everyone coming on the show
expects that like who was Abed girl
Amanda Stanton Lauren B Jojo Becca Tilly
well she wasn't really she's looks like
a recycled right uh just good ones and
they all have a million followers yep
and so he's just gonna get like a lot of
thirsty girls and that's true know the
show was self-employed Aang mm-hmm with
the thirstiness they're drowning in
their own thirst but that's why paradise
is so great because it's all about
thirty like the first two you are the
better the content right and the better
it's like on The Bachelor you have to
pretend you're not thirsty for like four
weeks and that's really hard for a lot
of people whereas it's encouraged in the
bachelor in paradise in bar and people
can just be their true selves and it's
premium content yeah so I don't know how
we can have bachelor in paradise without
having to suffer through The Bachelor
but maybe what they'll figure it out
someday but I the one thing I am here
for is production like changing up who
they choose like Ari was like a good I
think a good choice even though people
don't like him I like love him and
Lauren and I said Lauren encouraging
message and did she open it well she did
like a couple Instagram stories like
literally crying she's like you guys are
so mean to me and like at the end of the
day like first of all she didn't do
anything like she fell in love Ari like
have a bad situation in an decent way
like I don't think it was terrible
people just don't like them and that's
fine but like I think people are still
me so I'm like I see what people say
about them in our group and like it's
mean and that's like private like I can
only imagine what people say to her face
that's private and they know we like
them yeah and so like I don't know I
felt really bad first so I just sent her
a message and I was like honestly like I
was just like being encouraging I was
like honestly I'm such a big fan of you
and Ari I love you guys and like please
don't let anyone bother you but with
things
they're saying she's like thank you so
much but I couldn't believe she said
something cuz she's like seems really
shy and like I feel like it's so hard to
say something because it feels like
you're paying more attention to your
haters than the people that love and
support you so it was really so loud and
bad but usually that formula works when
like your lovers definitely outweigh
your haters but I think literally
they're haters outweigh the people who
like them I think there are more people
who don't like them as a couple then
people that do which is so upsetting
because they never did anything bad no
and Becca's living the [ __ ] dream as
a Bachelorette like what's wrong what's
their problem everyone's hurting other
than you Sally with your mean Instagram
everyone's got a happy ending yeah us
too yeah I will no longer tolerate the
bashing of our Ian Lauren well without
further ado I literally would have
forgotten Oh food it's your birthday
where's my lighter you were sitting on
it I saw oh right oh you knew I did
that's all later I'll sit that's weird
um
just is that one that sings yes are we
allowed to blow fire in here oh I don't
know
well nobody stop it so we're good we're
good here I'll take that thank you so
much exits it's awful oh we have a
special performer coming to sing happy
birthday my playing it's Stevie Wonder
[Music]
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear
Claudia happy birthday to you thank you
so much thank you happy birthday sister
thank you for coming to work on your
birthday we all love you so much we're
so proud of you and we're so excited
what to see what you accomplished in
your 24th year on this earth and you
don't look a day over 18 thank God
too many more too many more too many
more toastie birthdays I'm so excited to
see where we're celebrating your
birthday in a year from now totally or
your birthday in six months from now
it's just gonna be an exciting ride the
toasters love you I love you happy
birthday Make A Wish make a toasty make
it count
you should I tell you my wish but I'm
not you know oh except why would she
tell him her wish ever then it doesn't
come true that's the number one rule of
wishing that there's a literally one
rule on your birthday don't tell anyone
your eyes and honestly as the premise
for the movie it's flawed you know it's
a big big there were a couple you know
what there were a couple things in that
movie that they were like pushing like
even just the kissing booth like they
can't it's it the movie could have been
just as good without the kissing booth
being like a center of the movie and
like and without the line that's sang
the kissing booth was everything and
then it change lives
right they kept bringing it back to the
kissing with words like I totally forgot
about the kissing it's like right it was
an unnecessary metaphor like a symbol
that they were pushing so I like movie
didn't even need to be called the
kissing with literally the curve just
been a moment at like a school carnival
where there was a kissing booth and she
got tricked into this thing and like the
kissing booth didn't need to be like a
focal point of the whole stupid movie
right it couldn't even come between two
brothers yeah the because thing with had
more lines then Noah then the little
brother Leo Leo whatever his name was
yeah Leah but lately anyways happy
birthday sister thank you guys for
tuning and we will see you tomorrow
right now I
you